thank you strong winds are driving a new
fast-moving wildfire in northern
california's wine country the so-called
glass fire began yesterday before dawn
it quickly burned through
acres of vineyards and threatened
hundreds of homes one hospital had to
evacuate dozens of patients
when the flames got dangerously close
jonathan vigliotti is tracking the
damage
the glass fire more than doubled in size
as the sun went down sunday
bearing down on the town of deer park
which is under
mandatory evacuation orders
[Music]
fire evacuation and progress officials
ordered hundreds out of their homes
early sunday morning
as the glass fire destroyed buildings
and threatened neighborhoods in northern
california's napa county
there's a mountain right there and you
could see the flames and it was just
really scary because it was just like a
line
of flames hospital officials in the town
were forced to use ambulances to
evacuate some 55 patients as a
precaution
the area is home to some of northern
california's biggest wineries which has
seen
multiple fires in recent years it almost
seems like year
after year after year it is becoming
more of a norm
but this is the closest it's ever been
for us high winds
fueled the flames throughout the day
destroying decades-old wineries it's a
cremation craig betwello's family has
raised grapes in saint helena for more
than a century
the hill where the rum bauer winery is
i've hunted that a lot i know all the
trees and area
and they were dissolved mandatory
evacuation orders were also issued in
shasta county
just west of reading california after
another fast moving blaze grew to 7
000 acres within hours on sunday burning
multiple structures
high winds continue to be a major threat
in this area
as red flag warnings are in effect until
this evening
for cbs this morning jonathan vigliotti
los angeles